hey everybody lebron here
got another quick brain teaser for you
do i have a better odds of making three
free throws in a row or one
three-pointer
here's my friend sal with the answer
excellent question lebron but before i
enter it i want to point out an
interesting trend related to your
question that i just dug up this is from
the new york times october 2009 so it's
a couple of years old but it's really
interesting it shows that since since
three-pointers were first introduced
they were first introduced in the
1979-1980 season the three-pointers have
become more and more frequent so what
they are showing here is the average
attempts per team season by season it
looks like there's just a steady upward
trend here and related to our question
there's a couple of anomalies here and
the ones that really jump out are these
three seasons in the late 90s and that's
because the actual three-pointer line
was pulled in because to essentially get
higher scoring games so people attempted
more but then it was put back to where
it was originally this was a shortened
season and i'm not really sure what
happened in this what is this the 2000
2001 2002 season here but it's something
to think about that there is just this
trend that more and more people are
taking three pointers now with that out
of the way let's think about your actual
question and to answer it i dug up your
stats right over here from nba.com and
we'll look we'll use your career stats
so we want to compare we want to compare
three free throws to a three pointer so
right over here we have your three
pointer percentage and this is in your
career and i'll round it to the nearest
hundredths so it looks like it's about
33 percent so your three point
percentage is we'll just call it 33
percent and then your free throw
percentage
your career free throw percentage so
this is free throw percentage and this
is in your career we'll round to the
nearest hundredths so we'll round up
right over here that gets us to write it
about
right at about 75
so clearly looking at these numbers
right over here you're much more likely
to make a given free throw than making a
given three pointer you're more than
twice as likely to make a free throw but
that's not what you asked you asked what
about three free throws in a row and so
what we'll do is we'll do an analysis
very similar to the last time when we
accessed about 10 free throws in a row
so let's think about the first free
throw so free throw
number one if we imagined a gazillion of
a billion gazillion's not a real number
if we imagined a billion lebron james's
identical lebron james's all taking that
first free throw
we would expect on average that 75
percent would make that first free throw
so 75 percent is three-fourths so 75
percent would make that first free throw
and 25 percent we would expect on
average won't always be the case this is
what we would expect 25 percent would
miss that first free throw now let's go
to the second free throw
free throw
free throw number
two and we only care about the ones that
the lebron james is that keep making
their free throws so let's think about
of the 75 percent that made that first
one some of the 25 percent might make
that second one and then maybe even the
third one but let's just think about the
ones that made the first one of the ones
that made the first one we would expect
75 percent of them to make the second
one
so 75 of this 75 that's half of the 75
that's about 75
of the 75 percent would make that second
free throw and the first free throw so
now we have this is going to be 75
percent times 75 percent now and of
course there's other there's other
combinations out here where someone's
missed at least one of the free throws
now let's go to the third free throw
free throw
number three what percentage of these
lebron james is right here will make the
third free throw well 75 percent of
these will make the third free throw so
75 percent of this number so let me just
draw it visually that's half that's
about 75 percent of that number
they will make the third one as well and
so this is 75 percent of this number
which is 75 percent
of 75 percent
this is how many lebron james's are
going to make all three of the free
throws
and once again we can write this as we
could either multiply it out or we could
just write this as 75 percent to the
third power which is the same thing as
75 percent literally means 75 per 100
same thing as 75 over 100 to the third
power which is the same thing as
0.75 to the third power and so let's
calculate it get the calculator out and
so actually let me show you we get the
same result we can write 0.75 times 0.75
and on this calculator that little that
little snowflake looking thing it means
multiplication times 0.75 and then we
get we get 0.42 i'll round to the
nearest hundredths and that's the same
thing we would get if we got .75 to the
third power once again 0.42 so let me
write that so this gets us this this
gets us to approximately
0.42 which is the same thing as 42
percent so your probability of making
three free throws in a row is 42 percent
which is still which is still higher
than making one three pointer so i'll
leave you there but i want the people
who are watching this video
to think about what would happen if the
numbers were different or maybe look up
some nba players or maybe some college
players where their probable and figure
out and compare the probability of
making three free throws to a
three-pointer and see if there are if
you can find any players where their
probability of making a three-pointer is
actually higher than making three free
throws in a row